A one-day vacation, and that's so a little busy, yeah.
Ohh.
Ready for the weekend?
I'll just catch up on my emails.
That, like this.
Yeah.
Yeah, it.
Do we have Sophia joining us?
Yeah.
That should.
Let's see.
Okay.
Ofia.
Hey, Lee, good afternoon.
Hi, Lee.
Hello, everybody.
Again, Ray. Hi, how are you?
Hi, Tammy, how have you been?
Doing very well, thank you. It's a beautiful day here in Jersey.
It's a little chilly in Toronto.
Hello, Sofia.
Hello!
Hey, how's it going?
All good, and you?
Feeling better?
That's good.
Okay, that's Ray.
It's like it's cold, Sophia, where you are.
Yes, it's cold yesterday and the day before it was amazing, the weather, but today again it's cold, but it's sunny, at least it's sunny.
Mhm.
Yeah, that's great. Tell me, how about you?
Is it hot? Do you know? Okay.
It is cool. It's like 8 degrees right now, Celsius. Same thing yesterday. Yesterday was nice. It's about, I think it was like 15, 17 degrees yesterday, the highest.
Yeah.
Yeah, thank you.
I wish I could say that.
Today and tomorrow, debate.
How much? How much?
You mean you are you talking about right centigrade?
Team.
Yes, Celsius, yes, Celsius, yes.
Yes.
Rodge.
But...
She said 15.
The 15th, yeah.
15? Yesterday we were in 25.
Yep.
Twenty-five.
Twenty-five, but today we are in at 9.
We were 25, two months back.
Now it's 40 here.
Yeah.
We are, we are trending upwards, you know.
Okay.
Yeah, that's great. Are we waiting for Ray?
I asked them, so I'm not sure.
Okay.
Sophia, how did this week go?
BC.
BCBC.
Yu.
Ray.
Yours.
But busy, yeah.
Missy too.
Yeah.
Calls and other activities, so me, Amit, and we were on a different call just before this one, and we have another to do just to do right after this call, and then we have another call, so...
Ohh.
At least two hours affected.
It's the life between the meeting sesh.
Yeah, tell me something that I don't know thoroughly.
It shouldn't be like that. It should be 10 minutes meeting, that's it.
World Nights.
Bob.
Wish that was true. That was a dream come true, Sophia.
Thank you.
Yes, because it is saying you lose so much time during meetings and you have to do another thing that's like, oh my god, do I really need these meetings?
Mhm.
Do you also get meeting notes after the call through AI, or you do not follow it as of now?
I don't.
Sophia.
OK.
I don't think so, no.
Lucky.
Yeah.
Alright, well I guess until Ray joins, can we start?
Fischer.
Okay, great. So thank you so much for joining the call. We'll first start with Sally. So Sophia, how's she doing?
Payment application is getting better and better. That is really good. She still has few queries that we are working and how she has to find the information from the clients. The thing that seems that it didn't have an improvement this week
It's working on the billing board. So she still is struggling, closing tickets and trash the tickets and responding to the clients. So that is something that she needs to keep working.
Okay, so did she reach out to you for the queries or is it something that she was not aware of?
Okay, so one example is the tickets that we have with the remittances. So the client sent the remittance, and once that we receive the payment, you need to close the ticket. Otherwise, you have hundreds of tickets open, even though you receive the payment. So she has to do every day.
or at least one every two days or something like that, checking that whatever is open is really open because we didn't receive the payment. So I request that on Friday and she said that she work on that. When I have been working on the board for queries from clients,
And I saw that she has still like 40 tickets open. So I went through some of the oldest one and payment was received at the end of March or beginning of April. So those tickets should be closed. So I went through with some and say, hey, you didn't check this one.
So let's check what happened. And she was like, because I didn't receive, we go to QuickBooks, you receive the payment, so you just have to close it. So I think that maybe she forgot to close it or she needs to check those tickets.
So that is something that is happening and she needs to improve that.
Okay, I'll work with Sally on that. Second was I had a word with Sally before this call and she was referring to I think a discussion she had with you yesterday where you checked the board and some of the tickets were not touched and when you rechecked and by...
Yes.
by the time we recheck, so the entire board was clean. And she said that you were happy because you didn't expect her to do it in like a limited time, but she was able to do it. So was that from the service board?
Yeah.
Yes.
Yes, yes.
Yes, that is from service board. So the example that I gave you happened on Tuesday or Wednesday. Today is Friday. So Wednesday. So she worked better on Thursday and on Friday.
Okay.
Great. Thank you. But I will still connect with her so that it remains constant. It should not be like, OK, got it.
Yes, it has to be constant, yes.
Hello, Ray, how are you?
I'm fine, thank you. How's life?
Ray.
That's good.
Okay, great.
Rodge.
Have you been kicking?
OK. Anything else, Sophia, you want to share or Sally?
No, it's just the billing board that she's still learning how to triage the tickets and everything, but just that it's something that we have to keep working.
Yeah.
Okay, great. And another thing, Sophia, you raised in the previous Connect that you were considering of moving her shift timings. So you said that you would check with Tyson internally. So I just wanted to check if it happened or if something that you want to keep it for some time.
We haven't had the approval yet, so let's see maybe next week.
Okay.
Alright.
Thank you.
Yeah, for sure.
Right, Tammy, so over to you for Krishna.
Krishna.
Well...
A lot.
I think, Tammy, can I reply?
Yeah, please, yes, please, yes.
OK, so I, I think I is a Krishna is a...
Close case now for us. We will have two guys coming back, A.J. and Madeline. They will join us beginning of the first week of May. So, yeah, I think Kris has close case for us. So, she's working with us, doing her part, and that's it from our side. Yeah, we have some comments, but...
It's not really, anyway, because the tweak is sends a notice already, so...
Yeah.
But he's doing her best, let's say this way.
Yeah, so Rave, at least our expectation would be that till the end of June, right, till the time she is with working, at least she's delivering all the expectations that we have, right? I mean, her work is, time is being utilized in the right way. So that's the expectation we will have. And our approach will be to continue to work with her.
Yes, sir.
Yu.
Yes, Kris.
Yes.
wherever you see that we can bring the value to you, irrespective of how long she's in the system.
Yeah, yeah.
I think, yeah, saying this, saying that, I think we are fine. Then we have some comments, some comments, but we can discuss it. We don't have it in writing right now, but maybe next week or in our next call we have it in writing, so we can discuss with you. But I think it's, we can say like 80% is the best.
Yeah.
OK.
Alright, Brian, do you have anything for Sally?
No, Sophia is working with her closely, so I don't have any comment on that.
Okay.
What's up? Yeah, go ahead.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yeah.
I hope it's visible.
Yep.
Okay, so I would like to 1st discuss on the scorecard piece, Ray. This is for Krishna and Sally both. Where I was asking you to please fill in the numbers for the analyst so that we can have it documented for their quarters.
Yeah.
Also, we can rate the engineers accordingly, internal, so can I expect to get me these numbers once I share this service call tech post this call in the email?
So, you are waiting for Siri or Krishna?
Yeah, because these are the quarterly numbers. So for Krishna, it should be for Q1, Jan, Feb, March, and same is for Sally.
Gupta.
Yeah, of course. Okay. Can you send me this in Excel or?
But.
Yeah, sure, I'll share it with Nikki.
Yeah, simply in Excel, copy Tammy and we can go through it and we can send it to you by Monday.
Alright.
And for Sophia, I will work with Sophia so we can do it also send it to you by mid of next week.
Okay.
But he is a little bit busy with the AR and stuff.
Absolutely, I'll share it in the email and Excel file. Thank you.
Yep.
Thank you. Thanks.
Next I have is performance analysis. So this is the operational overview for Krishna. On the basis of the connect, this data is from April 17th until 20th. So within this time, Krishna was available for three days only because one of the day she was on sick leave.
Okay.
So she booked and closed on 105 vendor tickets during these three days, with her average at 35 tickets per day. In addition to that, April 17th was a peak day, where she worked on vendor board closures and invoice updates.
Other than that, she worked on PO and invoice records to make sure the financial tracking is there. She also worked on purchasing email, purchasing email box and contribute to vendor communication and issue progression.
So this is the overview of what Krishna did in the previous week, three days to be precise. And this is what we have captured on the basis of my connects with Krishna. And when I go to her ticket board and see the work that she did towards the end of the day. So any comments?
Yeah.
Ray, you have.
No, nothing from my end. Demi, do you have any comments in this?
No, nothing. No, I'm good. Yeah.
Tell me.
So, get a line that this data is inaccurate, right?
What?
Yeah, your average is, yes, your average is like 40 to 45 tickets a day.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's right, yeah.
Yep.
Yeah.
All right, thank you. So I have not considered the payment orders in this because in several vendor board tickets, you have multiple payment orders. So that would, if I would have included that, that number would have rose to 180 or 120.
Yeah, of course.
So I just considered the regular service board tickets and I did not include the relevant PO tickets which were getting generated out of the vendor tickets.
Yep.
Kour.
Okay, I'll move on to Sally's data. For her, this is 97 total tickets that she closed in this period. Average is 24 tickets per day. Her peak day was April 22nd, where she closed the maximum number of cases.
And there was no productivity data observed, so she did work on quick book payments, query then communications, as confirmed by Sophie already.
So yeah, this is the gist of what Sally did in the past week. Sophia, please let me know if you have any questions on the slide.
Nope, it's accurate.
Okay, so we will work towards the billing piece that you mentioned and the vendor queries. So I will work with her to make sure that utilize her current knowledge and go through the previous tickets also that she can take reference from and proceed accordingly.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Yep.
Let me quickly unshare my screen.
And on a similar line, Sophia, I also have a question. So it happened, I think, 2 weeks back, but it came into my mind because it is from vendor queries. So excuse me, one of the queries says that a user mentioned that remove my name, not remove my name.
add this person's name to next month's billing.
So, but it was not mentioned to remove my name, the requester's name from the billing piece. So, so this was a query that Sally had, and she was a little reluctant reaching out to you because it was the initial phase of the feedback which I shared with her, but she thought if she would reach out to you, you know, I mean.
Yeah.
So this is what happened. I think ultimately she reached out to you and then you clarified her. So queries of such nature where things are not correctly mentioned and decision making would depend on prior experience. I hope you are okay if...
Sandy reaches out to you for such queries.
Yes, of course. But always if, for example, I'm busy, I'm in a meeting in a call or whatever, she can reach out to the customer and ask for clarification.
Yeah.
Yep.
That is fine, and she can ask me anytime.
And I believe she should not reach out to Wendell directly to get clarification or she can.
Yes, you can do it to the customer, yes, yes.
Yes.
Again, OK.
Yeah, correct, so I'll make sure that this happens. OK, so this was piece that was that I was even I was not clear about, so I'll convey it to her.
Music.
Yes, it's better to be clear than making something silly and changing things if we are not if we are not clear on that.
Yeah.
Got it.
Alright.
Any other feedback additions?
No.
No, nothing for Manu.
Demi.
Don't go to, yeah, nothing.
Amit sir, anything you want to add?
Nope, I'm good too. Thank you.
OK, set up from CX standpoint.
No, now you are already taking care of the things, Ashish. Thank you. We just need to make sure that the concern which Sophia has made will be addressing with Sally. So all good there. And Ray, I believe this is our last connect before you move out. So just wanted to wish you all the very best for your future and Damien.
ITBD.
Yes, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Thanks, sir. Thank you.
and definitely we'll be in touch.
Sure, thank you. Wish me luck, wish me luck.
It was a pleasure working with you, Ray. Yeah, I wish you all the best.
He.
All the best, all the best. Wish me luck.
Yep, that's it.
Yeah. It's why I'm on the call today. I'm unmuted.
Lee, you are muted, yeah, yeah, no, you are notified.
S.
Ohh.
He.
Oh, no. Yeah, no. I was going to say, it's why I joined today. I heard of your departure, Ray. I know we only interacted on a few occasions, but it's been a pleasure as much as it has been. So best of luck with everything.
Hello, here.
Shh.
Likewise, likewise here. Thank you. Thanks, Lee.
Yeah, thank you. Of course, of course.
So, yeah?
All right, yeah.
Cool.
No.
Thank you so much, Ray.
Pleasure welcome today. Thank you. Thanks, everyone.